Paltrow skis down to the right.
She turns her head up
to look at her children
as she turns her head back down.
She screams, then skis
that into the back of Terry Sanderson.
She rides us back down.
They hit the ground hard and Miss Paltrow
bounces off of Terry.
The weight of both of them, their bodies.
Cause Mr.
Sanderson's ribcage and his arm
to smash into the ground,
breaking four of his ribs,
two of them completely.
Sanderson's helmeted
head hits the ground,
causing a concussion as his brain strikes
the inside of his skull.
Sanderson is face
down in the snow, unconscious.
She's skiing,
enjoying herself.
And she hears
suddenly she sees two skis
appear between her skis
and a man
comes up right behind her.
Now they're not going fast.
That's kind of the odd thing here.
He comes up
almost body to body like this
and starts groaning.
She doesn't know what's going on.
What's going on?
My being assaulted.
She's moving forward.
And then she's like,
there, begin falling to the right
and she's
feeling
freaked out, I think is a fair statement.
And he hits down
apparently his side
and it's his head
and she is essentially falling on him.
But keep in mind, his skis
are intertwined now with hers.
Her first reaction
is get away from this.
And so she's going
trying to get away
what has just happened.
Now, she only has to think about this
for a few seconds
to realize, okay, I'm
not I'm not being assaulted.
But this fellow, she had a more colorful
word, has just run into me.
And she said, what are you doing?
Or words to that effect.
And he he's like, I
was the effect.
I didn't see you.
And then there's a question, well,
who ran into who?
And he says, Did you?
You ran into me and it's like, No,
you ran square right into me.
And he said, I'm sorry.
He doesn't deny saying I'm sorry.
He doesn't remember it,
but he doesn't dispute it.